hey higher nice day nice to speak to you
I I think to be honest I think the major
issue is for people to get to know their
local MP because I don't I don't I've
I've been sort of a voter for a while
now and I haven't seen my local MP I've
just seen kind of like letters been sent
to my house and I'd like to get a chance
to speak to my local MP to be honest to
get to know what their policies are and
and to get to know what whether it's
going to benefit me and what what's
going to benefit me in the future Chris
tell us whether you think it's modern
technology might help a little bit
sometimes people say you know younger
voters need to connect in a new way with
a democratic process so for instance you
could have a skype surgery you know why
go into the the office of your MP why
not do thy skype why not have election
hustings using social media does that
make any sense to you or does it sound
like gimmickry at I think that's a fair
point I think I think people people need
to make use of technology i mean younger
younger people are more up to date on
technology now so why not make it might
not make use of it but also i think
technology I think modern technology
it's got to be used in the right way
because I think modern technology we've
seen over over over time people can get
a caught up in scandals if it's not used
the right way but they've got to make
sure that that they're they're
connecting with with younger voters like
ourselves so I think that's a valid
point yeah we're